[music playing]
NARRATOR: Jack Begley, Gary
Drayton, and area geophysicist
Mike West head to
the beach on lot 26,
located on the island's
southwest shore.
They have come here in hopes
of finding historical artifacts
like the gold-covered brooch
Gary and Rick Lagina discovered
just one week ago and
which was estimated
to be as much as 700 years old.
This looks like a
point here all the way
down there with the boulders.
This could potentially be--
Yeah, there's definitely
something going on here.
--a landing spot.
Yeah.
And what do people do
when they come up by boat?
They lose stuff getting
on and off boats.
Yep.
And especially if
they were possibly
loading and unloading stuff,
let's see what we can find.
Maybe we'll get lucky.
All right, let's
get her going.
All right, mate,
we'll follow you.
OK.
NARRATOR: To assist
them in their search,
Mike will use a metal-detecting
device known as the EM61.
Unlike conventional metal
detectors, which are generally
limited to an average scanning
depth of between 1 and 3 feet,
the EM61 is equipped
with powerful transmitter
and receiver coils, allowing it
to sense metal objects buried
up to 20 feet deep underground.
It also features a GPS device,
which will allow the team
to record the exact
location of any targets
too deep to be dug up by hand.
Come on, Mr. West.
Find us something good.
I'll find something.
Think he's got something?
Any idea of the size of it?
Yeah, something here.
It's quite small.
But in this area
here where I just
kicked off here a little bit--
[beeping]
Yeah, I'm getting it.
It's only reading 4 or 5 inches.
What?
All right, that makes it easy.
Do you want to check?
Yep.
[beeping]
Oh, it's out right there.
I see it.
Yep, I see it.
[beeping]
What is it?
Hey, look at that.
A welding rod?
No, look at this
tip on the end.
Oh, shoot.
That is unbelievable.
That looks like a
bleeding bolt. Wow.
That looks like a crossbolt.
Totally.
NARRATOR: A crossbow
bolt on Oak Island?
But how did such
an unusual object
come to be in Nova Scotia?
And perhaps even more
important, who brought it here?
That is sweet.
I mean, this is old.
We're talking,
like, Templar old.
No?
Yeah.
That's when they used them.
That could be anywhere
from 1000 to 1500.
Hey, Gary?
Well, we'll show you
what we've been up to.
What is that?
It's a weapon or
a crossbow bolt.
Yeah.
Exactly, crossbolt or arrow,
but I think that's a crossbolt.
And if that's a crossbolt,
that is very, very, very old.
And something like
this would have been
used for piercing chain mail.
Templar, baby.
I'm using the T word.
[laughter]
I think we were all blown away
by the potential crossbow bolt.
Gary is saying it's
very, very, very old,
and this type of
crossbow bolt was
meant to penetrate chain mail.
Well, chain mail is medieval.
So it's possible that it might
go back perhaps to the 1200
or 1300s, perhaps even earlier.
So it's an exciting find.
There's no question about it.
I mean, that is
fantastic, crossbolt.
You guys are smiling now.
We knew you would like that.
That is cool.
This shape might be--
The head of it--
--culture
influence or some way
to define where it came from.
Laird and/or Kelly
Bourassa would
know something about this.
But you're right.
That's a find right there.
And it's exciting.
It is.
The example.
Well, I don't know
which is more exciting,
this or what yet remains to
be found in the Money Pit.
But it's all about
now continuing
to search and do research.
I feel like we just scratched
the surface in this area.
I can't say anything but
thanks for all your efforts.
Great day, you know?
Great day.